wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn from challenges with oprah
winfrey nobody's journey is seamless or
smooth we all stumble we all have
setbacks if things go wrong you hit a
dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me
what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
uh who's written this wonderful book uh
called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead
and the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power rule number two don't be
distracted with bill gates recently you
said that the biggest mistake you've
made professionally
was that um microsoft should have had
the android technology why was that the
biggest mistake well
when you're in a field you know we were
in the field of doing operating systems
for personal computers we knew the
mobile phone would be
very uh popular and so we were doing
what was called windows mobile
we missed being the dominant mobile
operating system by a very tiny amount
we were distracted during ironing trust
trial we didn't assign the best people
to do the work so it's the the biggest
mistake i made in terms of something
that was clearly within our skill set we
were clearly the company that that
should have achieved that
uh and we didn't we allowed this
motorola design win and therefore the
software momentum to go to android and
so it became the dominant non-apple
mobile phone operating system globally
rule number three remove friction with
jeff bezos it's about definitely about
leaning into the future um and so
uh when you look at the kinds of things
that you want to be able to do with your
voice
uh you know it it changes for for those
of you who have used an echo the fact
that it's always on
that you never have to charge it it's
always sitting there ready in your
kitchen or your bedroom or wherever you
put it the fact that you can talk to it
in a natural way
removes a lot of barriers a lot of
friction a lot of like little tiny
pieces of friction to be able to do
things to ask what the weather is it's
easier than taking your phone out of
your pocket and what what has what
people have found over and over again is
that by removing the tiniest amounts of
friction from ordinary activities really
people appreciate that and and it
improves customers lives rule number
four know your destination with grant
cardone how do you maintain a positive
opportunistic upbeat attitude during
times like this
you know i i look i struggle with it
just like everybody else this is not an
easy time it's scary uncertainties
everywhere
bad news everywhere
uh the thing the thing that i continue
to do is
i was just telling jared a few minutes
ago we're just thinking too small
you know let's let's we're thinking too
small
and so like i'm like where am i going
where am i trying to get to
uh because i could be seduced into a
beach right now pretty easily
yeah i'm gonna go lay on the beach
and i don't need to do all this
you know and then i'm like wait a minute
there's no beaches open either like
there's the caribbean shut down the damn
st bart's is shut down there's uh
everywhere you go there's problems right
so there's no getting away from that
where am i going yeah
so so i the thing i need to wake up
every morning hey i'm still going for 10
billion worth of real estate maybe 20.
yeah
why not 30.
so how do i do that got to stay relevant
got to keep paying my bills got to take
care of my properties got to show people
that i know how to get through tough
you can't expand if you if you fold
every hand you can't win if you fold
every hand
so you got to play the cards you got
right now it's tough
and then but i have to keep making
contacts with people that can actually
benefit me in 21 22 23.
i got i got to be i got to be a beacon
of possibility and potential and future
uh so so that when we go when things
start lifting off and we can do deals
um i'm relevant to the conversation and
i got to cross my fingers dude and just
believe that
i got to believe that things are going
to get better hey man how you doing
buddy good how are you you got a book
coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five make a difference with elon
musk things that i've chosen have not
been
um
i've not been trying to optimize on a
risk-adjusted return basis
so there are
like i would not say that i went into
the rocket business the car business uh
or the solar business thinking that it's
a
it's a great opportunity i just thought
that
that something needed to be done in in
these uh industries in order to make a
difference
and that's why i did it so
um
but in general i do think it's worth
thinking about like what you whether
what you're doing is going to result in
disruptive change or not if it's just
incremental
it's unlikely to
to be something major
it's got to be
something that's substantially better
than what's gone on before rule number
six embrace sustainability with jack ma
first as a technology company
we believe in technology is great for
human beings
we believe technology can create a lot
of jobs
because human beings every technology
revolution create more jobs
but when the early stage every
technology
create worries
worry if you do not manage them the well
it's going to be a big problem as i said
the first world war because of the first
technology revolution
second technology revolution caused the
second world war
and this is the third technology of
which we're coming
then
as
alibaba
we believe in the future we believe
technology will be increasing
sustainable
and people worry about environment using
technology
to solve the environment problems we
only have one earth this is we
everybody's we only have one
when people using
oil coast
if we think earth is
it's a human and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is be persistent with mark cuban
when i got to dallas i was a bartender
at night and i moved in one of my
buddies from indiana said you gotta come
to dallas and i'm like i'm there you
know my car would only get so far i had
a fiat x19 with a hole in the floorboard
that guzzled oil every 60 miles and i
went down there and there's a place
called the village it's the world was
the world's largest apartment complex we
had six guys in a three-bedroom
apartment i didn't have my own room i
didn't have my own drawer i didn't have
my closet i had a pile and i had one
ratty towel that i stole from
motel 6. um and that was it and so i was
looking for my career got a job at the
software store and i was you know
i was didn't have a tech background so i
was teaching myself all this because the
way i look at tech is somebody invents
it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it and if
if i work harder and faster to really
dive in if it means reading the manual
you know just diving in then i can get a
head start
i was 24.
and so sleeping on the floor working in
a software company you know learning
learning learning learning learning
getting better at what i was doing and
then one day because i was dying to get
out of that rat hole that i lived in um
i had a chance to go out and close the
sale for that would have got me a 1500
commission and so i went to my boss his
name is michael humecki and i said boss
one of my responsibilities was to sweep
the floor wipe down the windows and open
the door to open the store i got the
sale you got to let me close the sale he
goes no you got to be in here to open
the store
and i'm like michael i mean no so i made
the executive decision to go out pick up
the check thinking if i had this guy a
15 000 check
of course he's going to change his mind
fired me on the spot
and so here i was
living in a show excuse my french you
know just this ratty place with a motel
six towel sorry motel six um
and
and really didn't know how i was going
to get out but i went to i decided okay
i'm a lousy employee i went to um one of
the companies that i've been talking to
architectural lighting and i said look
um i need 500 to be able to buy the
software you want and i promise you that
even if it doesn't work i will wash your
car you know i will walk your dog i
don't care what it is i will do whatever
it takes to make it up to you and they
gave me the 500 and that allowed me to
create micro solutions and you know six
months later i was out of the rat hole
and my company turned into a real
company and that's the one i sold um for
six million dollars when i was 29 30
years old now i've got a really special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week the sign says that when
you just watch a video you get motivated
to get inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you it
does not matter
who you know
it matters who knows you um so i'm going
to go up i'm going to go i'm trying to
get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji but what if it's already booked
they can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming they're like hey mr cardone i
want them calling me i don't want to
call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you people do
business with people they know it's how
business has been done for 2000 years in
this plan not people don't do business
with people they trust they do but they
first do business with people they know
i got to know you before i trust you
and i would rather do business with
somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day
i have to don't you think there's
there's an element of so for example but
i know that would have been this deal i
know they can get the deal done with me
right like the real estate broker i know
i'm not getting quite the truth from him
on this or that but you know what he's
got the deal i just did two deals i did
120 million by the real estate deals
with the same guy
i don't really like him right but i'm
doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like people ask
me why e-commerce so successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china
one of the reasons why e-commerce in
china is success successful because
china had a terrible infrastructure of
commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have so many like walmart kmart
everywhere
it's it's just a terrible
backward
retail system in china where internet
e-commerce come people love it so so
efficient
why china mobile phone you know grow
much better than america america and
europe have such a great such a great
system of telephone we don't have 10 of
them
right amount like 100 family can only
have one telephone that days when mobile
come we love that which is the goal that
so there is a leapfrog
we don't have that rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what the
internet look like so that leave us a
chance to grow fast
europe
very interesting you have such a perfect
rules or loss
then everything you do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about the thing they do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about they start to worry when they
worry they make a rules loss
when we have problems we start to solve
the problems
then think about rules or loss
you have a problem that can make rules a
loss
so
i worry about europe
i worry
i worry about the worries of the europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have solutions for
artificial intelligence oh you know
they're going to destroy a lot of things
in human life
forget it
let me tell you artificial intelligence
i think
we alibaba using artificial intelligence
to arrest and catch a lot of thieves
my theory i told my engineers i say
now when you love somebody you may not
have reasons
but when you
hate somebody
you have logic and reasons
we have logic and reasons machine can
always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many
cheatings human being cannot do it so we
teach machines to catch all the thieves
machines never forget
no matter how smart you are one person
can create 10 ways of cheating you are
the smartest person in the world but we
teach the machine
every way everything with this discover
from other people the machine can
remember over a hundred thousand ways of
cheating when you start the cheating
machine find you
so
one way
bad guys using artificial intelligence
doing bad things other thing we using
artificial intelligence to catch bad
guys
so there is always in any unbalance
how you see the world if you see
technology revolution is a problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started
if you think it's an opportunity
opportunity just started the only thing
is
your mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
by the way
all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready
everything's perfect
why they need you
because there is worries because there's
problems because of there's no this know
that that is your opportunity that is
our opportunity and
keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little ten years later you'll
be different that's that's that's who we
are sometimes it's like god has other
plans it's like something hits you and
you don't even know and well frankly the
things going through my mind were what's
you know what's what's going on what's
wrong with me uh
i would try i would spend my makeup
trying to cover it up because rosacea's
bright red and you get these um patches
on your skin and they're textured like
sandpaper like a rush right almost yes
and it's very textured and so um no i
mean i think any time
you know something happens to us whether
it's a physical thing a physical change
an emotional
situation um something with our health
right any time we have something like
that you know the the
it's hard
to go through the the beginning of it
because i struggled a little bit
honestly i had thoughts like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed i never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just started doubting
myself i started um
doubting okay is this going to affect my
career you know but
in in the midst of the the start of kind
of that that i guess struggle of going
okay
my physical appearance is changing let
me wrap my head around this um uh is
when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on on uh
every product i could get my hands on
from the most expensive to the least
expensive and and there's that famous
saying like you know sometimes we make
our mess our message and that's sort of
what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem and there must be
so many other people that have just
given up on makeup because it doesn't
work for them and it's like okay
nothing works and and the more i
researched i'm like wow seventy percent
of women have hyperpigmentation wow all
yeah yeah that's like oh you know what i
mean and so many of us deal with just
all different uh things hormonal changes
everything acne and so i just thought
you know what
if i can solve this problem for me i
know that it could be you know of
service and life-changing for for other
people also and i was filling up my
calendar with so much non-essential
stuff yes non-productive things because
i felt obligated to say yes to lunch
meetings you meet this guy for 15
minutes we take this call and i just
didn't want to be like oh jesse's an
[ __ ] he won't take this meeting or so
i would just do it and i realized like i
was losing control of my own time
and like
i lost control of my own time so i just
said i started saying no to everything
canceling everything that that wasn't
going to really that i didn't need to do
right there was other people putting
demands on me
and i really started focusing on me i
mean i think so much of business is a
reflection of you
and so many of us don't
don't invest in ourselves yes so i drew
a little pie chart of my time of how i
want to spend my time
and in my 24 hours i broke it up into
four different sections and i make sure
that every day i have three hours for me
so i can you know because i think it's
just so important that we put ourselves
first
and we really don't so many of us don't
occur to you that zip2 might be
a success
well i mean when we first started out i
think our ambitions were really quite
quite low um
it was really to make enough money to
pay the rent yeah we we got a vc give us
money that was
yay
we thought it was all over then yeah it
was pretty crazy i mean when we started
at 95
we literally at the beginning we had one
computer
which um would be the web server during
the day and and then at night i'd
program on it
um and
we'd sleep in the office yeah we
couldn't afford to to yeah
it was cheaper to rent the office than
to rent an apartment so we just rented
the office and stepped in the office and
showered at the water ymca
and for me the worst part was eating a
jack-in-the-box three times yeah man
this is like i'll sleep it's really
difficult to get food at palo alto after
like 10 p.m um it's like jack-in-the-box
and a few other options
we rotated through the jack-in-the-box
menu through the end of 95 where that's
essentially we're just sleeping in the
office and charging the ymca and then
um
and around the end of 95 is when
netscape went public and
and then
whether or not somebody knew what the
internet was they knew that you could
make money on the internet somehow
or even if it's only on the greater full
theory so
when we went and talked to venture
capitalists in early 96 there was a much
greater
interest in what we were doing
um in fact the round closed in like
maybe a week or something it's crazy
yeah we went from sleeping in the office
to people throwing i mean again this is
a financial crowd so you guys see these
numbers every day but for us to here
we'll give you three million dollars
yeah sounded extremely we thought they
were crazy like why would they do that
it was literally like these people are
insane they obviously do not realize
we're sleeping in the office
in fact when they when they did fund us
they realized that we were illegal
immigrants well
yes we were i'd say it was a grey area
yeah yes we were
i was there we were illegal immigrants
we were sleeping in the office we didn't
have a car we had one car with the wheel
kept falling off but well actually yeah
the the wheel didn't actually fall off
the car oh yes exactly um and then and
the venture capitalists actually bought
us cars
yeah well like i gave us 40 grand it was
40 grand to go buy cars which was at the
time was more money than we ever seen i
kind of knew deep down inside like okay
i'm i'm created
for more in the sense of like i have
more to give and and more to create
um and more to serve and more to see
and i always kind of knew it
and i went through this really lifelong
journey though of like
like like knowing i i was kind of
created for more but doubting it anyway
and
kind of my whole life actually and maybe
a lot of people out there may be in the
same spot and it's kind of why i wrote
the book because i feel like
while it's my story of going from a girl
who didn't believe in herself to like
believing in herself and not not
trusting herself to learning actually
how to kind of like break through all
the self-doubt and hear that inner voice
and like and trust it um go from
doubting i'm enough to really on that
journey of knowing i'm enough and and
it's i just think it's well it's my
story i feel like it's so many people's
story out there my dad did upholstery on
cars so if you got a rip in your car
seat you would take it to where he
worked um
my mom did work odd jobs
from wherever and we you know we had
we lived in an okay neighborhood
um
but we weren't poor by a long shot but
we were truly middle class and i
over and over my dad didn't go to
college my mom didn't go to college
and so they would beat into me you're
going to college and they used to make
me work at odd jobs so that i would
learn the value of work and and you know
one i'd go where my dad worked doing it
with cars
and he'd make me sweep the whole and
this place was nasty make me sweep all
the time you know
tried to get me a job in the middle but
couldn't give me a job in the mill
my mom wanted me to lay carpet because
she was worried about me if i didn't
have a trade and so she got a friend of
hers to try to get me to teach me how to
lay carpet and if you ever go there's
this little office in pittsburgh
pennsylvania if you trip over the carpet
that's where i learned how to lay carpet
um
and i was going through these things i'm
like this is just not me and and i
always had that that individual spirit
to say okay you know i can come up with
things that can make me money i mean
when i was nine i would sell baseball
cards when i was 12
i told my dad i wanted a pair of
basketball shoes and it just so happens
he was playing poker with his buddies
who were all probably drip roaring drunk
at the time and i just didn't realize it
but i was like dad i want a new pair of
tennis shoes you know the the new beta
bullets were coming out or whatever they
were
and um new converse and he's like you
see those shoes on your feet
they work just fine when you have a job
you can go buy whatever you want i'm
like dad i'm 12. i don't have a job and
one of his buddies stood up with
nostrils but he said hey i got i got a
job for you he had these boxes of
garbage bags
and he's like i've got these boxes of
garbage bags i don't know what to do
with why don't you sell them
i'm like cool
you know
what do they cost me and they literally
were a box of 100
these blue garbage bags that he would
sell them to me for three bucks and then
i would i went door to door i was like
hi
my name is mark
do you use garbage bags
and i learned i could sell it's just
like okay six bucks you know i'll drop
them off whenever you need them just
call me and i made some money bought my
shoes and you know and that just gave me
confidence and it took off from there
lucky
in life if you can find your passion i
tell the students you know what you may
have to take a job or two you know
you got to eat but
never give up searching for the job
that's your passion try to find the job
that you would have if you were
independently rich that's the job i have
and when you find that job the job that
causes you to be excited every day
and forget about the pain
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that my partner charlie
is 89 and we were talking about that
this weekend you know i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living
does not equate the standard of living
and the standard of living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside i
love to ride around in a private plate i
will totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i could live on
easily live a hundred thousand dollars a
year and then it and i wouldn't live i
wouldn't live better if i had eight
houses if i hadn't you know a 400-foot
yacht or anything of the sword i've been
on
400-foot yachts and i've been a lot of
fancy houses but i'm in a house that i
bought
55 years ago
it's
warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer it has everything i wanted plus
it has all kinds of good memories you
know my kids have good thoughts about it
i can't imagine living any better i paid
thirty one thousand five hundred dollars
for it i could pay 31 million for a
house and and it wouldn't it wouldn't do
for me what this present house does and
you've got 440 000 customers 145
countries
um
where do you go from here
well uh we want to make sure we beat
amazon and cloud database
so funny to hear you say that i mean
that that's that's simple very simple
it's very simple uh it's just like
playing basketball if you know if you're
playing basketball you want to beat the
warriors you want to be you know uh you
want to win the championship
so
our job we have the best database in the
world uh we've got to
deliver it in the context of
a cloud that's as easy to use as amazon
but secure
and that's the key thing education
is essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they have
available uh
you know i took
these numbers won't make any sense
anymore but the hardest freshman math
class was called math 55
uh
i assume it's not called that anymore
but it was it was a group of
uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math that they had ever
met so there were 79 frauds uh
one
person who really was the the best at
math i ended up the guy who came in
first in the class is a lawyer in new
york now
the guy who came in second as a
professor of chaos theory of uh
princeton uh and then i came in third uh
so i knew okay math geez uh that's
interesting anyway
uh
i didn't take physics uh 55
but i read the feynman book and so
if you're motivated
seriously you don't have to take a
course the feynman book if you're
hardcore just read the finding book do
the problems you want to learn to do
software read the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but
you know anyone that's rated 30 or
harder is like super hard to do
and so
a mooc in a sense
doesn't change what counts
uh you know it's always been in the
textbook but the percentage of students
who just buy textbooks and and read them
and know the subject is vanishingly
small you kind of have to have this
thing where a bunch of kids all come at
the same time
uh
and you know if you don't study you're
going to get a bad grade and your
parents may not like that uh
you have to create all these social
things
in order for people to get into this
mode of hyper concentrating
and actually understanding why should i
concentrate you know if i'm a high
school student they put x's and y's up
on the board
how does that relate to my life now if
you understood that being good at math
lets you get a good job travel the world
you might say okay it does relate to me
but that's a very
indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that
to concentrate that's what's missing and
so moocs
to the degree that it's easier to take a
mooc than it is to read a textbook yeah
that's nice it's a little bit
interactive there's a video that's
probably why i like the learning company
like all their economics there's kind
named timothy taylor who has five
courses on economics i super recommend
uh
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
uh engage in that learning and how do
you create the environment and the sense
of achievement and the sense of
capability that sitting in there and you
know looking at x's and y's and
manipulating them uh seems like a smart
thing to do i wake up in the morning
what you do and the first thing i say is
thank you
that's my first thing
even before i'm awake even before my
eyes are really fully open i i say thank
you i can feel the gratitude like i'm
still here i'm in a body thank you so
much i thank you for that and then i go
through the letting the dogs out the
whole you know brushing your teeth and
all that stuff and then i have either
silence or prayer or something that
acknowledges that i'm still here i do
not reach for that phone first that's
your problem that's my problem that's
your problem 2008 in particular was was
was awful because
we had the third launch failure in a row
of
of our falcon 1 vehicle at spacex
and um
we uh
the tesla financing round that we were
raising fell apart
um because the economy is going to
tailspin um and it's pretty hard to
raise money for a startup car company uh
you know late 2008 when jim and chrysler
are busy going bankrupt
that was that was tough and then solar
city had a deal with morgan stanley and
morgan stanley had to renege on the deal
because they themselves running out of
money um so it looked like all three
companies were gonna die
and i was also going through divorce so
that was definitely a low point so it's
2008 you're going through a divorce
which like some
to borrow your word douchebag bloggers
are writing about to make even worse
right yes that's true um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on massively in the press right
yeah you're you know it looks like all
three companies yeah are gonna file i
mean
why do you keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like
i've already sunk everything i have in
these companies
and i gotta pick one
but you didn't i mean you kept doing all
three why um yeah that was that was a
very tough call
um
at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the top you know one of the
toughest goals i've had to make
because i could either
um
reserve capital for one company or the
other i mean before solar city didn't
need a ton of capital so they were they
were okay
but between spacex and and and tesla um
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids and
what do you do do you spend all your
money to to maximize probably the
success of of one or do you
do you try to keep both left
unfortunately it worked the first thing
is you got to differentiate yourself i
always ask myself why am i different how
am i different and i think it's very
important to be
i call them the three c's but clear
concise and confident you have to be
able to describe it in a minute or less
make it so clear the customer really
wants to make smart decisions and they
really want us to make it easy for them
so i always say make somebody feel the
pain or if it's not the pain
which means the problem on why you did
what you did or why you're creating what
you create then explain to them your
uniqueness and then right after that
you've got to give them the solution
very quickly and then take it through
and say why you're the best i mean very
quickly
explain to them in just a few seconds
why you're the best option steve jobs
cared a little bit too much about how
perfect the edges of some polygon were
right um
what is it that you care too much about
connecting everyone
no seriously if you think about i mean
it's like this aesthetic sense of the
world that i have is that you can
communities of people can channel their
energy to do great things and having
connections between people is the
infrastructure for the world to do that
and
you know that's why at each step along
the way when there was always all this
uncertainty about you know whether it
would be profitable or whether it would
make sense or be good or whatever to do
these things um
we always were doing it because we just
cared more and i mean to this day i mean
you could you could say that that was a
startup thing but it isn't because i'm
now where we're here and we connect more
than a billion people but i mean we're
pouring tons of money and resources into
connecting people who can't even afford
internet access right so i mean that's
like there's no way that that's going to
be profitable in the near term or medium
term but we're doing it because we think
it's the right thing to do and over the
long term i do think that there's
something there and it's going to be
fundamentally important for the world
and maybe we'll get rewarded maybe not
but we just really care throughout my
20s i continued experimenting trying
different things racing bikes and boats
and constantly changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover
that the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs were found at a cluster
of companies located south of stanford
university in north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my twenties when i went
to work for my first silicon valley
startup
amdahl
where we developed the world's fastest
mainframe computer faster than anything
ibm had
next stop was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments
where we built an even larger data
storage system this time using lasers
i was the vice president and charged
with software development
it was all
very cutting edge and challenging and
cool
i like my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one
i put together a plan to start my own
company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew and we would all work
together on the most interesting and
challenging software projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me
a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people i think when
dreams start to brew in us or when
there's like a seed planted in us where
we have this dream it kind of started
that way where i was like like it was
like a little inkling like wait a minute
if i if i could figure out how to
launch how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people and then i would kind of
like silence that dream and i would my
head would take over oh jamie you have
no connections you have barely any money
you don't know anything about the beauty
industry
and you're you're in your dream job
right now right and so it was i went
through that battle and i think everyone
listening to us right now probably like
really if they get still they probably
know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they know
what they're supposed to create or go
after or offer the world or start
painting again or start dancing right
they kind of know
um but sometimes our head talks
ourselves out of our lives absolutely
dreams there's this culture in silicon
valley that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting a startup
and
my goal when i realized that i had a
company was to get it to be a good
company as quickly as possible right and
kind of get out of what you'd call the
like risky startup phase where you are
just like constantly about to die and
where you could get to a point where you
can actually do some interesting things
and make make a lot more interesting
bets
and um
so i don't know i never read a lot of
the literature on this and i mean maybe
if i had then i wouldn't have made so
many mistakes but so i don't know if
like if learning for me is the right way
to go on this but i mean but it did
i think your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional right like were
you influenced by peter thiel or sean
well yes people see all these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before i'm
talking about like yeah right yeah but
he was massively influential on my
thinking right i mean like a lot of the
uh the early lessons that i took on how
to think about strategy came from peter
and sean and
i did pay a lot of attention when i was
growing up to microsoft i thought i mean
i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like the
most unbelievable things and uh in a
sense they are yeah they really were
awesome right um well i don't know if
you you meant that positive positively
but i did well i look at a lot of
figures just in connection with our
businesses i i uh
i like to get numbers so so i i'm
getting reports in
weekly in some businesses uh
uh that but that doesn't tell me what
the economy's gonna do six months from
now or three months from now it tells me
what's going on now with our businesses
uh uh and it really doesn't make any
difference in what i do today in terms
of buying stocks or buying businesses
what those numbers tell me they're
interesting but they're not they're not
guides to me
if we buy a business we're going to hold
it forever so we're going to have good
years bad years in between years maybe a
disastrous year or something here and
and
we care a lot about the price we do not
care about the next 12 months economic
predictions just don't enter into our
decisions charlie mugger my partner and
i
in
you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction we make business
predictions about what individual
businesses will do over time
and we compare that to what we have to
pay for
but we have never said yes
to something because we thought
the economy was going to do well in the
next year or two years and we've never
said no to anything
because we were right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right i was
sort of wired for capital allocation and
being wired for capital allocation a
couple hundred years ago in nebraska
wouldn't have been a thing
uh and and even now being born in
various parts of the world i wouldn't
have been much but here i was in this
soon-to-be very rich capitalistic system
and and it just so happened that what i
did paid off enormously in a market
system like we have and i if i'd had a
talent in some other area that was way
less commercial i mean i would have i
would have had a good time doing it but
it wouldn't have paid off like this but
of course jay said it perfectly when he
talked about
you know he's in the recording for
himself and the money comes afterwards i
mean i
i got to do what i love i mean and
it doesn't get any luckier than that if
if you can spend your lifetime and i'm
80 now and doing things you love every
single day i mean i would be doing what
i did what i do now and i would have
done it in the past if the payoff had
been in seashells or sharks stings or
anything else
if you can go to work every morning i
tap dance to work you know and i come
down and i every day is exciting and i'm
gonna tell you something that a lot of
people 99 of people disagree with me on
right everybody says follow your
passions
i say this [ __ ]
right i say follow your efforts
it's amazing how we're all passionate
about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great
but
no matter what it all nets out to where
do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something and you know what
i've learned nobody ever quits anything
they're great at
and once you get great at it it's
amazing how passionate you become about
it
follow your efforts
right because it's not in the dreaming
it's in the doing a great entrepreneurs
should not have a money if you have a
money in your mind this ice is us
dollars this is iron b and you're
talking like english pounds nobody
will work with like
if you have a good dream
if you have a plan to making things
making progress things were happening
and i changed my mind to this morning
just
half an hour there i would do more
things
in africa and the only thing i want to
do is not to sell
products here
and i will enable you to sell your
dreams all over the world in africa
supporting entrepreneurs is always my my
dream because i know
how tough it is to be an entrepreneur
it is difficult
i never cry i said i only make my
competitors cry
because if i
cry i probably die a hundred times
because we have to encourage our team
and i say
making sure that we
that we can survive tomorrow as i said
before i answer question
i want to say this is my belief
and this is what i tell every day to
myself today is difficult tomorrow is
much more difficult but the day of
tomorrow is beautiful most people die
tomorrow evening
even today as my size
for our company's size
i still believe
today is very difficult i have more
problems
than anybody here can imagine
you say ah now you are big you make
billions of dollars
every you know quarter
i have much more problems than you have
much more headache than you have i think
people need to define what commitment is
for me when i commit to something the
next two things that will happen is it
will be on a schedule requires time and
i will invest some money
all commitments
for me require time and money
if i don't write a check i'm not
committed
if i don't have if i don't take time out
of my calendar i'm not committed so if i
want to work out okay my body started
starting to cause me some problems right
so i'm like i'm committed to taking care
of my body
what did i do wrote somebody a check
show up at my freaking place every day
at seven o'clock
and i'm gonna work out okay that was
four months ago i've missed five days
in 120 days
that's commitment time and money you'll
see something be curious be interested
and do more than just the you know the
casual hey it's nice to meet you it is i
mean if i if i find someone that's
inspiring or an event or something i try
to introduce he she or it to my life
and that's part of just my own personal
development you know i'd learn better
through experience than through books
i like to be challenged and i love
interesting people i like people that
are think differently that act
differently that's what attracts me
that's just what makes me feel like i'm
getting the most out of life you know
and that is
i'm on the constant search for that
because i'm very aware of my own
mortality you know i'm 50 years old i'm
turning 50 and the average american
lives to be 78 and if that were the case
and i was average that means i got 28
years left
and that dictates well who do i want to
spend that time with and what do i want
to do
and that's a driving you know it's like
on repeat in my head
so to answer your question you know
that's that's sort of what makes me tick
if you're having problems right now
okay like like if you're having
recurring problems
just make a list
make a list of
make sure you guys do what grant says
remember he's a t-rex
yeah yeah make a list
make a list of your recurring problems
that you're sick of
the same stuff over and over again man i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough money
uh i i don't get to take whatever the
recurring problems are i can't good good
people uh uh i i got a i got one person
in my office that i depend on and i'm
sick and dependent on him even though
he's a producer
those recurring problems that you have
over and over again
uh you lose deals you lose you don't you
don't like your clients you actually
have clients that that you'd like to get
rid of you know how you get rid of bad
clients get more of them
okay so what i do is if i have problems
let's say i'm making a million dollars a
year i'm making 1 million
and i'm like okay next year this is what
this is what business owners do
they're like i'm this year i'm going to
go from 1 million to 1.2 million i'm
going to get a little growth and then
covid cracks you
and then you're like okay i'll settle
for 500 grand now
the problem was you were looking for
incremental growth okay you know the old
thing about three steps forward two
steps backward you only get one step out
of that by the time by the time a week
or two goes you're like i'm sick of this
i'm tired i'm bored
i'm beat up and your life doesn't change
the trick is
that if you would plan out how to get to
10 million even though you're not let me
just go ahead and asterisk that right
now
don't have a plan to go from one to one
point two
build a plan to go from one to ten
million because it's going to give you a
new set of problems
okay and a takeaway for you today get
new problems
because if you keep
working on the set of problems that you
have you will never solve them
okay watch uh i got a handful of
problems i'm making a million dollars a
year or 200 grand or whatever your
number is pick your number
and i'm like i'm gonna get me
incremental growth how do i do that with
the people i have the time i have the
office i have
well what you do is you're like i'm
gonna go from one million to ten million
oh i need a new office new problem
oh i need ten people not two people
oh i need to spend
a hundred grand a month on advertising
not five thousand see got all of a
sudden i got new problems
i'm no longer thinking about pete the
the the the uh
uh what do they call the guy that you're
so the diva the diva jessica i gotta put
up with jessica's [ __ ] because she's
a diva comes in when she wants leads
when she wants
uh she runs the business even though i
own it she tells me what to do she's
really the boss even though i write the
checks
okay so i'm like i'm gonna go get 20
jessica's you follow what i'm saying i'm
going to build
like a lot of you are worried about debt
i remember in 2008 i owed 50 million
dollars to the bank
and i'm like i told my wife this will
never happen to me again the bank was
pushing me around like bullying me
around like a punk
and and i said elena this will never
ever happen to us again and she's like
what are you gonna do to prevent it i
said the next time this country goes
upside down i'm gonna owe a billion
dollars in debt i think one of the
things i want to share with the values
the six values among the two values very
unique and alibaba which i think the
whole world should think about we put
custom number one in priority number two
shareholder number three most companies
in wall street they put the shareholder
number one i said
each
customer is the most important if you
serve them well they pay you the money
and the second important is colleagues
why the college get together because
they want to serve the customers if they
do not cost serve the customers why we
get it together
right so if the customer happy in price
happy the shareholders will be happy my
grandparents would take me every summer
eve starting at age four
every summer
kind of to give her a break really
for the whole summer so i'd be with my
grandparents and on their ranch in
catoola texas which is halfway between
san antonio and laredo
we lived in houston
and uh so we would make the five hour
drive out to catoola they'd drop me off
spend a couple days there then they go
back to houston i'd spend the summer and
i went every day to the ranch uh with my
grandfather to help now a four-year-old
boy
on a ranch
in south texas is not a lot of help
but i didn't know that i thought i was
helping and um and then as i by the time
i was 16 i actually was helping
so i have you know i i can
i can
suture up a prolapsed cow
i can fix windmills
grandfather was so resourceful
and that he made his own veterinary
needles he would take a little piece of
wire and pound it flat with a
with like a oxy acetylene torch
and
then drill a little hole through it and
then we would do we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
and uh
so we had but we had great fun out there
you know um we built barns and welded
things and he bought a d6 uh caterpillar
bulldozer
used like
1955 model year
for five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped and then
we spent you know a whole summer
repairing that the first thing we had to
do to repair it was build a crane to
take the gears out of the transmission
and so
you know what i learned from watching
him was just how resourceful he was he
didn't ever call a repairman he figured
it out started with a much smaller
rocket falcon one
and was your goal at that point when he
started with falcon one to get to the
point where we had nine inches from
falcon 9 was that your goal at that time
when i started spacex i i only thought
there was maybe a ten percent chance of
getting felt than one two officers i did
not at all think that this would happen
uh so this is for sure dream come true
um
uh but i i literally at the time i
didn't know anything about rockets uh
and i was you know i've been the chief
engineer of spacex since day one and i
don't hear anything about rockets which
is why the first three rockets failed
right um and then
so the first three falcon ones for space
actually failures yes and then
tell me about uh
the fourth one so i had actually only
had enough money for three three flights
um so i don't know what money they have
to manage
so
team sort of rallied and we managed to
put together enough spare parts to pay
to do a fourth launch and that both
launched was successful
um and
uh so what would happen if it wasn't
successful oh we were spacex for tonight
so we would not be here right now
at this moment getting ready to launch
crew dragon to the international system
every single day to channel our own
inner jucindas
to exemplify the truth
and the respect
and the grace
that we actually wish for the world
we need to tell it as we're doing at
this conference we need to write it
we need to sing it we need to proclaim
it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness the love that we want to
see
and when we do that mark my words a
change is already
coming we haven't had any existential
crisises knock on wood i find i don't
want to jinx anything
but we've had a lot of
kind of
dramatic events i remember
there early on
we only had 125 employees
when barnes noble who the big united
states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us barnesandnoble.com we'd had
about a two-year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about three billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were um very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and um
and so i called an all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you okay is the you
know
it's usually the moms um calling and
asking their children are you gonna be
okay so and i said look you know it it's
okay to be afraid um but don't be afraid
of our competitors because they're never
going to send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them in in in in
instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is the the what
your response to it should be to double
down on the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them i know you all
understand better than most that real
progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say
that the single most important lesson i
learned in 25 years talking every single
day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood
i've done over
35
000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance and anonymity of our world
doesn't cause us to lose our ability to
stand in somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation i call myself a girl who really
likes to challenge herself to do things
that scare her to auditioning at disney
world
i ended up at disney world because i
failed the lsat and i felt very
sad that i most likely wasn't going to
be heading off to law school i am a
terrible test taker so i did what my
parents said of course would be the most
natural thing to do and i got in my car
and drove to disney world and tried out
to be goofy
and
just to add you know
insult to injury i'm too short to be
goofy so i just failed the lsat i went
through all the auditions to become a
character and you have to be five eight
to be goofy and i'm five six so i'm the
height of a chipmunk oh really yes
so they wanted to make me a chipmunk i
always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which is a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
[ __ ] wall yes and i was i always
every time i went around turned around
and went back home because i was too
scared i had crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city uh on long island in
the 80s when break dancing and rap and
all this stuff was happening and i was
really into breakdancing i don't know i
don't look like it and you know get some
cardboard out here man we need to do
something some cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money probably if i went to
washington dc you know because the kids
in washington dc couldn't be as good as
the kids in new york we invented this
whole genre so i got my friend myron
who's my partner my sister just got her
driver's license and i convinced her to
drive us to washington dc and the whole
drive down i was having all that
self-doubt yeah you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and i stink yeah and so i
was almost talking myself out i was
building the wall of doubt up brick by
brick in my own head yeah and when we
got there we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and the
crowd gathered around and ultimately
after i did my thing more people came i
took my hat and i passed it around we
made about 200 i paid my sister for the
gas money and then myron and i split
82.41
each and this guy you know he's counting
up the money and he's counting up the
money and he gets all the money and then
he sprints over to me and he gives me a
bear hug and he goes jess we're [ __ ]
rich
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall
and i realized i could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that what
keeps you so unbelievably grounded amid
all your resounding success
i i feel like success just makes you
more of who you already were
i feel like money and success just does
that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are people you know people
always ask me that and i'm like i don't
know who else to be i mean i am who i am
so the money the success
and um so i like to say if you were a
jerk before you got really successful
and a lot of money you usually become a
bigger jerk usually and if you were
insecure you'll become more insecure if
you were nice you'd become nicer if you
were generous you'll become more
generous it's literally just
a magnifying glass but yeah i am
i don't know how you know people ask me
i don't know any other way to be
just
going through it figuring it out along
the way you made an interesting decision
when you started uh microsoft not to
have dual a dual class share
and so many of these silicon valley
companies do today
what do you think of that i think it's a
mistake and i've said that to everyone
who's asked me it's enough as an
individual to really feel like
you're responsible for the success of a
company
to actually go and short circuit the
governance mechanism where if you really
are making mistakes that your board
can't outvote you that you literally can
just replace the board the next day
how kind of hubris is that i mean if
you're really doing a good job you
really think you're at risk of that i
didn't want i felt enough responsibility
for making sure microsoft succeeded that
i didn't want to be the dictator of
microsoft
[Music]
if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you know that's not really how it
works if you don't love it don't expect
others will either your relationship
with time is such a key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly